I met my first husband Jeff, we were
in a singing group in the Catholic Church. That was what we met.
We fell in love and got married in a small christian church in Brooklyn.
We married for about two years before I got pregnant with our first son Jonathan.
My second son was born in November of 1985.
I remember we had gone to New York. I
guess when he was about 5 or 6 months old.
A friend of mine had, you know, contacted me that he was sick with HIV.
So it was the first time that HIV had really hit close to me. I actually knew someone that had HIV.
So that was really the first time that, you know, it came that close to me.
I didn't know at the time hearing about his illness that it would even come closer.
Our second son Joshua Paul was sick. He
was about, he was over a year old.
He started getting sick, just lymph nodes
swelling and just runny nose.
He was always kind of a sickly kid up until
that point.
He was, he was not diagnosed with HIV, you know, when he was with his doctors.
Let's put it this way he wasn't diagnosed with HIV while he was alive.
I guess it was in July of 1987 that we decided to get him tested for HIV.
I was pregnant at the time, with my third child.
So anyway, sad to say that his disease process just got worse and worse and worse until he passed away.
The phone rang and it was Joshua Paul's oncologist and she had some news for us about his HIV test.
It had come back positive. I was like okay well, you know during his cancer treatment he had some blood transfusions.
She says well you know they were screening the blood transfusions at that point.
There's no way that he could have gotten it from a blood transfusion.
The only way that he could have gotten it was from you.
I was just like me, excuse me, you know I
had always been the wife of one person.
I was faithful to my husband and I was, like you know, I'm not, I'm not a gay man.
I'm not, what are you telling me, you think you got it from me I don't get HIV.
I never had a blood transfusion. You know so I was like, already my mind was  working trying to figure out what happened.
Where could this had come to our family?
We were advised through our my obstetrician, and just different doctors that we were in contact with,
for all of us to get tested. So it was a very long drawn-out process back then.
But we all got tested. Jeff had tested positive for HIV.
I tested positive for HIV.
The fate of our unborn child was unknown at that time.
In December of 1987 my daughter, Anna Lisa, was born.
She was sick from six weeks of age, and from six weeks of age they diagnosed her with full-blown AIDS.
So that was really a hard pill to swallow.
After Anna Lisa passed away and Jeff's health really started to fail, at that point we just were sort of holding out.
We knew that there were a lot of things that scientists were working on to try to develop therapy for HIV.
So I guess it was a little bit too late for him in 1996 when boosted Boosted PIs came out and combination therapy came out.
But he was already in hospice care at that time.
So we did try to put him on it. But, you know, because he couldn't eat
and couldn't swallow, whatever, it just never really worked for him.
So he passed away in 1996. I felt like I was going to be next.
We lost Joshua Paul. We lost Anna Lisa. I
lost Jeff.
Jonathan was HIV negative, my oldest son. Then I felt like okay out of all of us I'm next.
That's how I felt, because it was just watching everybody just wither away and die.
Then you yourself having only 73 t-cells you just knew that you were the next one. There wasn't anything around.
I guess it was like the end of 1995, I can't remember the dates to be honest with you.
I went on combination therapy.
I was on Combivir which was AZT and 3TC or AZT and lamivudine with Crixivan.
I showed a remarkable recovery.
I became undetectable and had my t-cells above 200
and right now, I don't know, they're in the 600 range.
I've been undetectable ever since. So you
know it was just for me
the therapy that came out at that time was a literally a lifesaver.
I was diagnosed in 1987 but I knew that
I had it in 1985 because that's when my son was born.
So now here it is 10, 11 years later and you're saying,
here's these drugs, you gotta live now, figure out your life.
You know a lot of people had sold their insurance policies and things like that. I mean I didn't go ahead and do that.
So what does life look like now. You know, what does living look like now.
Part of living for me was always being involved in the church.
Being a member of a church. I was a member of a church and I started teaching a Sunday School in a singles group.
Everybody in my church, everybody in the singles group knew about my HIV.
So I'm like, okay I'm not here for a man.
I'm just here for friends, you know. But
there was a this guy, that I became friends with
in the singles group at church. We were just friends and
he kept like looking at me with these eyes,
like that didn't look like friendship eyes.
I was like wait a minute, no back off, you know we're not, we're friends you know.
So anyway was during that period of time
that Daryl Swanson entered my life, and
you know, started pursuing me in a romantic way
which felt so unusual to me. Because you know I hadn't done that for years.
You know, and I was just like, you know I have HIV.
He's like, yeah I know, so what.
You know and it was like really, like so what, are you sure.
He's like yea, so what, and finally we decided to get married.
Lo and behold in June of 2000 we got married and we've been married every since.